here i got one for you from conspiracy
music guru
we like conspiracies here right
one two three four
i told you so
[Music]
i told you that i told you so
[Music]
i told you
[Music]
but what's your take on 911 mr
conspiracy music guru because i bet you
i have a different one than you do
remember when i told you about building
seven
yeah you're the one that did it and no
one was talking about building seven
until
music guru conspiracy music guru was
singing about it
remember when i told you about the floor
right in the water
yeah there was no big people talking
about that either was just you
sad dear remember when i told you about
the new world odor yeah they've been
talking about that since i was a kid
remember that remember when i told you
about the chemtrails in the sky
oh god now we're going to the chemtrail
it's it always it always it always
gets getting really weird like you know
you start with stuff that legitimately
should be questions like the 911 stuff
there's a lot of poke a lot of holes in
that
and now we're in chemtrails remember
when i told you that nasa was full of
lies
remember when i told you about the ultra
mind control
well i just wanna say that i told you so
yeah
[Music]
his guitar says flat earth on it
his guitar says flat earth on it
remember when i told you about four
three two
hurts that is what's fourth what's 432
hertz can someone explain
like i don't really go down these rabbit
holes that much but what's what's 432
hurts can someone explain it to me i'm
sure what do you always know
what what's he talking about
it hurts my ears remember when i told
you about the vaccine agenda
yes i did
[Music]
i mean she does kind of look a dude the
dinosaur
oh boy he's one
hold on hold on he's one of the dinosaur
deniers
is this guy's one of them dinosaur
dinosaurs didn't exist guys
ah god that's the problem you have a lot
of stuff that should be
legitimately questioned and then you
have dinosaur deniers which
keeps the [ __ ] up with a dinosaur
denying for the love of god
climate change scam and yes sanja monach
is also a man
oh that's right that there's that whole
conspiracy theory that sandra bullock is
a man
which she's not um she's a woman
but what what
remember when i told you that there
ain't no clue
well i just wanted to say that i told
you so
i'm sorry but that means that you've
proved that the the earth is flat
you can't say i told you so unless you
have conclusive proof i know what you're
saying everything's photoshopped
everything in space photoshop spacex is
all fake and nasa's fake
i get it i get it i understand that's
fine but what do you have have you been
in space either like
you you're a little stupid your little
stupid flat earth [ __ ] is just as
flimsy
and you can't even talk mention flat
earth i guarantee you maybe not in the
chat now but
just mentioning invoking flat earth is
gonna have people in the comments
section
flat earth people they smell it they
know when you're talking about them
i told you so
[Music]
how would satellites work if the earth
was flat genius i'll explain to you what
they say
the satellites aren't in the sky that
there's these um
like towers like they they we use towers
like cell towers to communicate back and
forth so there's no really no satellites
that's what they're doing
[Music]
remember when i told you about the tv
flicker rate
and how it puts your brain in an alpha
state
what remember when i told you about
your theory
the guitarist for arrowsmith
remember when i told you about gravity
oh yeah gravity's not real gravity is
also not real it's
we're only staying on earth because of
god i think if correct
i'm correct remember
when i told you about paul mccartney
remember when i told you about direct
energy
remember when i told you about monsanto
well i just want to say that i told you
so
i told
[Music]
42 000 views
[Music]
brian's right how does water stick to a
ball man their arguments are very
childish
[Music]
oh and benjamin already covered this oh
i'm [ __ ] sure he has
[Music]
remember when i told you about the main
street media
okay but yes mainstream media is full of
[ __ ] you you they always mix things that
are true with things that aren't
[Music]
you're so called celebrities and
pedophilia
uh adrenochrome here we go
[Music]
remember when i told you about the
georgia knights though
oh that's right georgia guide stones of
course also that no no everything this
guy knows everything
see the thing is with conspiracy
theorists and and this is just
correct me if i'm wrong
but the problem with conspiracy
theorists especially what's kind of like
this is
um they never
you're either ones like this i'm talking
about you either
believe all of them or you believe none
of them
like these guys every conspiracy theory
is
true every single one
it's not like hey you know that that was
a little weird i don't know what's
happening there and someone's like okay
well there's nothing come on shut up
you have to believe all of them
you you have to believe every single
conspiracy theory
if not you're part of the machine man or
you're one of the sheeple dude
like stop it so every conspiracy theory
is not true
[Music]
that's a really good point pittsburgh
aliens exactly my point
the real ones are used
the ridiculous ones are used against the
real ones
so you when you lump in the stupid ones
then it makes the real ones they go
they're all dumb all these conspiracy
theories are dumb
remember when i told you about the false
flag operation
remember when i told you about 5g
radiation
remember that i've told you that
what i'm just wait told you about what
what where did they censor
remember when i told you about the false
flag operation
remember when i told you about 5g
radiation
remember that i told you that
what did he say that they muted
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
do so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what's funny with these
conspiracy theories for these flat earth
people and all that stuff is like
they they build this like this this
little community and and all they
they just [ __ ]
there's no stopping them everything is a
conspiracy
everything is if one thing is a
conspiracy which there are things that i
think are
proven to be true that we've been lied
to absolutely
you know i believe that but then
everything is a good